Okay, so the market has been open for 15
minutes here and looking at the NASDAQ
futures and the ES futures. The NASDAQ
has a pretty good
uptrend in place as well with the ES and
so I would say there isn't really
great constructive support levels. You
know, we might come down here and
bounce. Looks like we're kind of selling
off right now, but if you look at both
of them, we had a really nice move up
yesterday in a sell-off,
but right now it's just kind of chopping
um in this bigger sideways trend still.
NASDAQ has broken out a little bit more.
Um so it's definitely looking on the
bullish side overall, but also kind of
weak at the same time. And so in my
eyes, that's kind of just indecision.
and so makes me less likely to want to
touch it. Um, gold here is having a
kind of zoomed out on a 15 is having a
big move up here. It's kind of been
chopping around for a while, but now
it's had a big move yesterday and this
morning it's having a second one um and
going down to a fivem minute. Like this
is a nice uptrend that I would love to
try and short, but the problem is if we
zoom out to like a 30, there's just not
a great
level that it's at yet. You know, I'd
love it was if it was popping up here.
Here there it's, you know, kind of had
some chop and there's some previous
tops over here,
but it's still just not great. And so
I'll look at it and see, you know, watch
it and see, okay, well, does it set up a
really nice clean looking like double
top kind of situation where I can at
least catch a move down to here,
especially like maybe on a one minute
chart if it looks like it'll reverse a
little quicker.
And then oil is just kind of crappy
looking. Um, it's just kind of in the
middle of the zone. Maybe if it pops
down to here, but at the moment its
current trend is just kind of just a
sloppy downtrend. You know, that's not
interesting. You know, I want to see
something overextended
and, you know, popping up a bunch of
fair value gap indicators on like a
50-minute chart. Um, like oil, I mean,
gold here. I mean, this is that's that
was a 30 minute technically, but you
know, again, very one directional
getting overextended. It's going to have
to have a pullback at some point. That's
the main thing. There's also
some news
30 minutes after the market opens. Uh,
in terms of of severity, it says it's
orange. I think this one actually is
um Richmond M
Richmond manufacturing index is actually
green from my
sheet. So theoretically it's not that
big of a deal. Um but it will be up here
in like 10 minutes. So I'm kind of
waiting to see that. See if we can get a
reversal
in the NASDAQ. I think that's kind of
the biggest option at the moment. Um
especially after this reversing off of
that because we're just kind of in a
sideways range. There's also this low.
They're not great lows to be reversing
off of because we haven't like tested it
multiple times.
But with these early morning reversals,
sometimes that's all you need. And so
I'm okay watching that and taking a
quick stab on those on a one minute
chart.
Okay, this has sold off really fast on
the NASDAQ. And generally when this
happens, it could vb bottom and I'll
totally miss it. But also, we've broken
below this low. I like we could totally
get a failed breakout here, but I want
to see if I'm going to take a long, I
need to see how it comes up and tests
this level because otherwise I could
just come up here and keep selling off.
And with when there's this much momentum
in in this case, it's you don't want to
just try and jump in long out of the
fear that oh there's, you know, a ton of
cra this crazy move down and I can, you
know, catch the whole swing up kind of
thing. That's not what we're looking
for.
I didn't get long on this initial candle
because I it just needs to kind of break
with the overall
bullishness or or bearishness happening.
I almost need like a higher low here.
Even though this is technically a higher
low,
just having a little bit more
confirmation would be good. Um
the sizing here isn't
great.
for
half size. I'll probably double the
contracts to go like 600 risk which
would end up being like 700.
But I mean overall like
just doesn't look great. And this is how
you weed out crappy or not great trades
when you're unsure.
But if this comes down here and pops up,
I want to get long.
And I think I want to get long two
contracts
because that's what I was just looking
for. And I think that's a good enough
confirmation.
You know, I'll be nervous about it
because
I'm a little back and forth on the read,
but I think this is a good spot to jump
in long because of this double bottom we
have. We've hit a
a low from I think this is couple days
ago kind of Friday.
Um
and so we are in long. Just going to
pull my stop up below this double bottom
and I'm probably just going to go for
2x here. Um just because the market is
pretty choppy.
Uh, I'm just going to switch up this
indicator here.
I'm kind of having some issues with it
lately. Just to show my actual
risk and profit. So, I'm I'm smaller
size than normal, kind of half size. Um,
mainly because this was pretty bearish
move. And
the level is
it's it's like kind of like the first
retest. But what I like is we have these
fair value gap indicators on a fivem
minute and the timing with 8:00 reversal
is pretty solid. And then a double
bottom here. And so I think it looks
good for a nice move up.
And I'm only going to go for 2x just
because
of this bearishness that we're having.
Um, also I've been sleeping like crap.
So,
um, I just won't be making as good
decisions tech potentially.
This is just a pullback. I'm probably
going to have to hold back. Hold
through. I mean, I think with the with
the way this trend is, it needs to have
this double bottom. And then some kind
of fake lower.
Um once this kind of breaks up here, I
think to break to 1x here, I'll probably
move here and maybe break even if this
really looks like it's going to start to
get going. um just because I think it's
either it's this is a really nice
constructive setup now and I think it's
either it's probably going to rip back
up here or it's going to come up here at
50% here and and continue lower with the
big picture
bearishness
taken into a play. And you know, again,
I'm just looking for this quick reversal
in the morning. Um and I don't want to
put risk on the table if it's just going
to not really do what I want it to do.
I will say this does not look great.
Part of me wants to
move my stop up here,
take the risk off
because we haven't had a fast bounce.
And it feels like it seems like the
downtrend could pick up. But also
in terms of big picture five minute, we
can still totally come down here
and bounce on a fivem minute on there,
five minute on here. I mean like it
would still be totally intact. Um, and
then if I got out at break even and I
saw a bullish candlestick form right
here,
I'd be like, "Oh, I wish I was in that
because
it it set up a very clean double bottom
on a five." And so I just have to even
though I'm feeling that doubt and
nervousness because it is kind of
choppy.
Um I'm just going to hold and because
the main big picture of the trade isn't
violated yet.
Is there the risk that it goes down?
Yes. And I lose? Yes.
But I don't want to get out because I'm
nervous
when there's no real market reason to
get out. You know, riskreward is there.
Um, and the big picture of of moving up
and giving back that snap down we had
from the market open is totally
possible. And so, you know, I think once
we break this is pretty much like a
little double top right here. Once we
break that,
I will move to break even at that point
because at that point it's it's had its
pullback that it should have in an
uptrend
and I'll want to get out at that point.
But right now it's just had this is the
first push higher and it could continue
higher after a pullback. Like a NASDAQ
here made a new high versus the ES
actually didn't. It basically made a
double top. Um, so just kind of waiting
for that to play out and
that's kind of the hard part about
trading.
Okay, we're getting a pop here. So, I'm
going to move to break even. Now,
sometimes I would move to the this low,
but if it pulls back off of that, I'm
just going to get out. Um, NASDAQ is
similar.
the five minutes. Like this is the five
minute pullback I was looking for. Like
I would have still wanted to been been
in if I got scared and got out there.
You know, the trade wasn't violated. Um
with the way the market is, it could
still just
pull back and knock me out of break
even. But again,
just managing it, I don't know what's
going to happen. I would love to take
2x,
but we'll just have to see.
Also, if you're wondering what trading
platform I'm using, it's called Ninja
Trader. I've used it for over 5 years.
It's amazing. I'll leave a link in the
description below this video if you want
to check it out.
So, as this gets going here and I get
close to this 2x target, I'm going to
especially once we get up to here, like
once we start getting a candle up here,
up to this price somewhere, I'm going to
move my stop loss up pretty aggressively
because there's no point in letting it
come up here and then rip all the way
back down, right? I'd rather just try
and get 2x at the most, but if it's just
going to come up here and pull back, I'd
rather just get out at like one and a
half. Um because this is a big move up
in, you know, a quick move to give this
back up, which is great, but it's been
kind of a a slow market. And so this
could really just reverse anytime at now
at this point. Um I you know it looks
really good to keep going higher. But
again big picture 50% pullback is um
based on this is just this dot right
here is literally right here on the
NASDAQ. So we're at the 50%. Um and ES
is
past the 50%. So,
I would love for this to keep going
higher. And I think if that's going to
happen, it's got this tight trend that
it's going to hold. And so, I'm going to
move up actually to 1x here. I really
almost don't want to because I don't
want it to come down here, knock me out,
and keep going higher.
But in terms of managing it tightly and
having this more fixed riskreward of
well I I only have a little bit more
profit to make. There's no point in you
know risking essentially $1,000
um to make you know another $400. That's
kind of how the math adjusts as your
trade goes. Um and so
I don't want to give all that back up.
Um, and and it doesn't make sense
mathwise. Um, and so hopefully it holds
this, but again, it looks like it could
just have a pullback here. Um, and you
know, I could have it down here, but you
know what? I am I'm still happy if I get
1x on a trade. Um, it's a long, which is
harder to play. It was half size, so I
wasn't really super confident in it to
begin with.
Um,
and so I can be super bummed, but I'll
be a little bummed just because it does
look good. But again, it's it's given
back a lot of the move and it's not the
market's just not acting great in terms
of strength. Um, NASDAQ here, that's a
little bit nicer of a bottom to hold.
Um, but again, like I think this is ES
is going to hold this and and keep going
higher if it's going to hold. But this
uptrend is already kind of broken.
So
five minute NASDAQ just looks cleaner.
But again, this is this is where I'm at.
Okay, out for 700.
Still happy about it. Still a nice
trade. You know, jumped in smaller size
because of
how I felt about it. And you know, if it
if it just shoots lower here, I will be
very happy that I got out.
You know, I don't want to play this
struggle game of waiting for it to
continue higher slowly over and over
time. Not every day is going to be, you
know, amazing. Follow your strategy. Go
with what your read is. That's all you
can do.